[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 Juan Pablo lucumí está con nosotros
en el estudio Juan Pablo hoy vamos a
dedicar esta sección para hablar de la
economía de China y los nuevos casos de
19 que podría nuevamente volver a
paralizar el comercio chino y Por ende
por supuesto afectar a todos los
mercados mundiales Así es Raúl y es que
parecía que la economía china iba a
liberarse ya de estos bloqueos cuando el
11 de noviembre el gobierno relajó las
medidas anticovit recortó la cuarentena
y terminó con la suspensión de vuelos
pero todo cambió el 20 de noviembre
cuando el gigante asiático reportó su
primera nueva muerte por Kobe 19 luego
de seis meses las nuevas restricciones
han causado rabia en una población que
lleva ya casi tres años de encierros y
restricciones y esto además generó una
protesta en la planta de iPhone más
grande del mundo el fondo monetario
internacional incluso instó a China a
recalibrar aún más su estrategia Kobe 19
y pues
levantar las tasas de vacunación para
tratar este tema previamente hablamos
con Raquel León de la rosa del
observatorio de política china en Puebla
de México y esto nos dijo en este caso
creo que el tema de los rebrotes y que
de alguna forma hoy por hoy día hoy en
día china está acá logrando estos
números incluso muy similares a puntos
pico principalmente en ciudades clave
para la parte económica de de China creo
que es uno de los escenarios que de
alguna forma el gobierno chino pues más
quería no llegar a tener No creo que en
este sentido uno de los aspectos
importantes
no solamente se generan en función de la
especulación de commoditis como ya lo
estamos viendo a hoy en día Con respecto
al tema del petróleo y como esta
situación de los rebrotes genera
muchísima especulación principalmente en
el en el tema de los energéticos Y cómo
esto Pues bueno de alguna manera este
está todavía muchísimo más agravado por
la situación de de Rusia y Ucrania no
principalmente para algunas latitudes
del mundo Juan Pablo para nadie es un
secreto que estos confinamientos han
causado una contracción en la economía
china completamente Raúl en abrir el
Banco Mundial pronosticaba un
crecimiento de entre el 4 y el 5% pues
para este año tiempo después el gobierno
de chillín fue más optimista con el 5,5%
pero ahora la entidad internacional
prevé que la segunda Economía del mundo
se quedará en el 2,8% para fin de año si
Se confirma esta ralentización será la
primera vez desde 1990 en que la
economía china crezca menos que el resto
de la región de Asia Pacífico Pues el
Banco Mundial estima que para la región
habrá un crecimiento del 5,3% en
promedio
si bien hay que este poder ir observando
el propio proceso evolutivo de las
expectativas de crecimiento de China
donde pues definitivamente no ha sido un
buen año no O sea de alguna manera la
proyección que daba el gobierno a
principios de año no tiene nada que ver
con lo que hoy en día este se sea este
proyectado y por otro lado pues bueno el
hecho de que salgan estas entidades como
las calificadoras a generar este tipo
Digamos como de este de de escenarios no
tan cortitos para la economía china
obviamente tienen un impacto a nivel
global principalmente en algo que ha
sido pues este la crisis en términos de
suministro que ha sido uno de los costos
más importantes a lo largo de la
pandemia no y que en este sentido pues
obviamente
pone en cierta desventaja a a la propia
china dentro de su papel en la economía
global no obstante este pues también
genera o refuerza estos argumentos que
hablan de cambiar ciertas tendencias a
nivel productivo donde pues pasamos de
ciertas dinámicas del offsharing hacia
dinámicas más o que promuevan muchísimo
más el tema del New yoring donde
obviamente pues la captación de
capitales
prospectados para el próximo año hacia
estos países que puedan insertarse en
dinámicas New shoring puede hacer
muchísimo más atractivo que el caso de
China y la cuestión Juan Pablo es que el
mundo depende muchísimo de toda la
producción que se hace en el gigante
asiático y es por esta misma razón que
algunos expertos ya empiezan a hablar de
otras posibles economías que podrían
reemplazar el suministro chino al menos
pues en alguna medida por mencionar
algunos se habla de Turquía de México de
Indonesia e India Pero esto fue lo que
nos dijo nuestra analista sobre el tema
en lo personal si hablamos de economías
emergentes no visualizo tal cual al
bloque de los bricks como una posible
solución hacia hacia esto en dado caso
de que se agrave la situación dentro de
China sino que son en otro en este otro
tipo de economías emergentes como es el
caso de los que pudieran generar como
estados en claves este interesantes con
mercados este de alguna manera altamente
de alta demanda no economías como
Polonia como Rumanía como Hungría
podrían insertarse en poder suministrar
algunos de estos productos
principalmente para el mercado europeo o
la misma Turquía en este tipo de
dinámicas no y por otro lado pues
tenemos algunas economías del sureste de
Asia como es el propio caso de de este
de Indonesia este en algunos casos
filipinas o Vietnam ojo no acaparando
totalmente la capacidad de manufactura y
tecnología que tiene China hoy por hoy
pero que en este caso puede entrar como
contrapeso del Sur en algunas de este
aspectos y en el caso por ejemplo
latinoamericano de alguna forma Quien
cumple más con estas Este necesidades y
sobre todo por el tema de de la
renegociación del temec y pues es México
no en el cual pues se comienza a
vislumbrar la llegada de muchísimos
capitales como una parte de la lectura o
situaciones de emergencia en las cuales
pues china deja de ser altamente
competitivo bueno Juan Pablo y de esta
manera entonces finalizamos este bloque
económico y pues evidentemente hasta una
próxima oportunidad Gracias como siempre
por toda la información Seguiremos
revisando este tema más adelante Así es
Juan Pablo gracias